foreign
[Music]
all the important news infos about
movies and series as well as the latest
rumors about the next Hollywood
Blockbusters on the superhero side we're
talking about a potential third new
Avengers movie and how Dwayne Johnson is
related to The Flop of Shazam 2. there's
also info from The Last of Us leading
actress on the second season as well as
news about high-profile cast additions
to Gladiator 2 and the horror flick Five
Nights at Freddy's so stay tuned
the final episode of the first season of
The Last of Us has been available for
streaming since the middle of the month
shortly after the episode's release
those responsible announced some
impressive figures almost 8.1 million
users are reported to have watched the
finale so the spectacular series is on
everyone's lips particularly fans of the
video game from 2013 were pleased as
many elements of the game's conclusion
were also found in the series as is so
often the case after the end of a season
the question now arises as to how and
above all when the next season will
continue at the end of January HBO
unsurprisingly announced that a second
season was in the works but remained
silent about the further production
schedule the main actress Bella Ramsey
can now shed some light on the matter
Ramsay was recently a guest on the
Jonathan Ross show and couldn't help but
answer a few questions about the last of
us she revealed that it will take quite
a while before they will fight Runners
clickers and the likes again together
with Pedro Pascal she held out the
prospect of filming starting at the end
of 2023 or the begin beginning of 2024
though she doesn't have any reliable
information on the exact release date
yet either after the first season
already required more than six months
from the first to the last shot we can't
anticipate a release before the end of
2024 or early 2025. should the second
season like the second game have an even
larger scope than a waiting period of at
least two years is quite realistic if
you also take into account the detailed
set design and the complex
post-production work fans will have to
remain patient for quite some time
the Five Nights at Freddy's video games
are already among the horror classics
they may not be very complex but they
can provide some decent jump scares
bloomhouse certainly wants to build on
the success of the low budget games with
its film adaptation however they are not
skimping on the cast as the latest
addition to the group of actors shows as
collider reports Elizabeth lail is
joining the project many know her
primarily from the Netflix hit series
you where she starred as Guinevere Beck
the focus of Desire from the stalker
protagonist Joe she thus completes the
Freddy cast which already includes Josh
Hutcherson as Mike Schmidt as well as
scream star Matthew Lillard cat Connor
Sterling and Mary Stuart Masterson the
story revolves around animatronic
figures that develop a dangerous life of
their own the creepy characters are
being created for the film by the famous
Jim Henson's Creature Shop which already
brought the Muppets or the dolls of the
Dark Crystal series to life so we can
likely expect some nice handmade horror
instead of heavy CGI work filming began
on February first under the direction of
Emma Tami and it is expected to last
until April 6th we'll keep you posted on
more news about the Five Nights at
Freddy's movie adaptation
with box office takings of almost 2.8
billion US Dollars Avengers end game is
the second most successful movie of all
time beaten only by James Cameron's
Avatar from 2009 so it's hardly
surprising that many fans are already
eagerly awaiting the next installment
the release date for Avengers the Kang
Dynasty is set for May 2nd 2025 and its
sequel also has set a theatrical release
date of May 1st 2026 already regarding
the latter new rumors have now emerged
Alex Perez's Twitter account was the
cause of it all seemingly based on
Insider information the tweets
explicitly talked about the upcoming
Secret Wars movies that's right the
plural was not an oversight as the
account confirmed a little later with a
joking GIF so far Marvel has not
responded to this rumor however it is
not entirely unlikely that the MCU will
be expanded by three Avengers movies in
the coming years after all the comic
book originally offers more than enough
material for countless films further
news is available regarding an employee
who has been a key contributor to the
success of many MCU films over the years
we are talking about Victoria Alonso who
was in charge of post-production
animation and visual effects for 17
years now however this chapter of her
career is closed for the 57 year old the
reasons for which have not yet been
publicly communicated whether the news
may have something to do with the
current MCU slack caused by the
moderately popular Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania or the quality of her work
can thus only be speculated as for who
will succeed Alonso in her important
position well that remains unclear at
the moment several MCU projects were
recently postponed in order to allow
more time for post-production this
affected the Captain Marvel sequel the
Marvels for example
the latest DC movie Shazam 2 Fury of the
Gods has only been out in theaters for a
few days the interest to the sequel in
Shazam which was released in 2019 has
been rather moderate so far which means
that the movie will not be able to match
the success of its predecessor the rap
reports that Dwayne Johnson along with
many other reasons is partly responsible
for the movie swap the 50 year old
Johnson himself faced failure in late
2022 with his pet project Black Adam but
he did have ambitious ideas for the DC
Universe beforehand Johnson and his
supporters hoped that the popular actor
would succeed in making a breakthrough
for the unsteady superhero universe as
we know things turned out differently
Black Adam flopped and the responsible
party signed James Gunn and Peter Safran
to help get things going as new heads of
DC Studios one of their first official
actions was to shelve the originally
planned Black Adam II and completely
revamped the DC Universe without any
ties to the so-called snyderverse before
the change in management everything
looked as if Dwayne Johnson would become
the most important man behind the scenes
PC as a result he was granted a lot of
say in other films according to the rap
Johnson had previously prevented Shazam
lead Zachary Levy from making a cameo
appearance in Black Adam he also was
said to have actively discouraged an
appearance by the Justice Society of
America and Shazam Fury of the Gods in
order to make his character Black Adam
the secret center of the universe indeed
director David F Sandberg already
confirmed that the original plans for an
appearance by the Justice Society of
America were scrapped shortly before the
start of filming of Shazam Fury of the
Gods however he did not provide more
specific details about Johnson's
possible involvement lead actor Zachary
Levy was much more candid about his
anger he shared the rap's article on
social media and added that it was
absolutely the truth the big question is
whether all this was really the main
reason why the Shazam sequel flopped so
badly at its release or whether there
were other underlying reasons at least
Levy went on to note that Shazam Fury of
the Gods had one major problem and that
was marketing on top of that the new DC
Universe has already been announced so
many fans probably don't see the point
in investing their time in the ongoing
projects have you already seen the movie
in theaters and what's your opinion
about Shazam 2 feel free to let us know
your thoughts in the comments
it was quite unexpected when a sequel to
the popular historical drama Gladiator
was announced some time ago after all
the original is almost 23 years old and
was more or less concluded in terms of
content the movie with Russell Crowe and
the leading role which was nominated for
seven Oscars and won five awards at the
time proved to be a success in all
respects this makes it all the more
challenging to convince fans and critics
of the sequel's potential we already
know that the plot of part 2 will take
place almost 25 years after the first
one and thus also depicts the real time
gap between the movies this offers
plenty of possibilities to introduce new
actors and set up a story of its own
among the actors are already some famous
ones and as deadline reports the cast
seems to be gaining celebrities recently
none other than Denzel Washington is
said to be part of the team Washington
has already worked with director Ridley
Scott in the 2007 Thriller American
Gangster and has been able to impress as
a battle-harden Avenger in The Equalizer
film series in the past years should the
rumors prove to be true he will be
alongside the presumed leading man Paul
muscal who appeared in after son among
other films also joining the project is
Irish actor Barry kogan who played the
Joker in a cut scene in the Batman and
like muscal was nominated as a performer
at the 2023 Oscars Mescal will likely
portray Lucius who is the now adult
nephew of Joaquin Phoenix's Commodus it
should be interesting to see how little
Lucius has grown up after the death of
his mentor Maximus at the end of the
film it'll be a while before Gladiator 2
was released in cinemas it is scheduled
to hit theaters on November 22nd 2024.
we hope there was one or the other
joyful news for you in this video be
sure to let us know what you think of
the latest updates in the comments and
feel free to give the video a thumbs up
and in case you haven't had enough MCU
content yet well our movie preview this
week does happen to be about Avengers 5
the Kang Dynasty so feel free to check
it out it's definitely worth it
[Music]
foreign